what are the
exteral to me the internal so if we're
we didn't get as a child or we we do
stand up and we get these but when
you're like I need to start a cult oh my
God to fix that thing that happened when
I was seven yeah you usually like the
people who become C wa do we kind of
have Cults though kind of yeah with like
fan you like a cult fan base yeah you
kind of you have a cult wait a
minute it is a joke yeah that like I
could be this weird the fact that people
listening to this are like you guys are
just catching on to the irony that
you're obsessed with Cults and you're
actively trying to I'm like my merch
come see me come see me live